[Musique]
pour ce faire un masque de protection
individuelle vous aurez besoin d'eux un
carré de 20 20 sur pour la face avant un
carré coton pareil
20 20 pour la phase du visage et un
carré de géotextile pour la filtration
donc voilà pour le tissu on va aussi en
doute et des élastiques
donc c'est une bande de 20 cm et 3 de
large
c'est suffisant pour tenir le masque
donc pour mettre nos élastique en place
il va nous falloir on va mettre
l'endroit vers nous celui-là n'a pas
l'endroit mais on va estimer que
l'endroit c'est celui ci donc en droit
en droit face contre face une fois que
mon tissu positionner comme ça je vais
enlever est allé chercher mon élastique
au mont élastique jeu le plus il est
trop large
on a trois centimètres par 20 lucien
licra on peut le plier ça nous réduit un
peu et l'important c'est à 3 cm de ce
bord là et j'ai panne
dans la
a première élastique mon premier point
d'élastiques et maintenant maintenant je
vais chercher mon deuxième appareil 3 cm
du bord de l'autre côté je maintiens je
veux bien avec mon doigt
je vais chercher mon tissu alors
vérifier qu'ils soient bien placés vient
droit comme ça la future ce sera
beaucoup plus facile
c'est un glaive la première les premiers
élastique sont mis on va mettre les
deuxièmes en face des premiers c'est à
dire on élastique passe ici à
l'intérieur on fait la même chose
on
et voilà premier fait j'ai plus qu'à le
mettre sur le tas de la suite on a notre
géotextile qui va venir être posée
dessus juste comme ça c'est à la couture
que ça va être tenu
[Musique]
on va avoir note de repères c'est à dire
le départ et l'arrivée de la couture qui
nous laisseront une ouverture de 10 cm
voilà donc le départ et l'arrivée sont
du même côté on est d'accord et on va
devoir faire le tour tout simple donc
voilà ça a été cousue alors on enlevait
les épingles les remettre dans leur
boîte
et puis on va retourner notre tissu
[Musique]
donc l'étape de la fermeture voilà notre
duo textile est bloqué dedans et on
vient fermer ça alors avec une structure
très vite fait
donc la dernière étape c'est
l'information des plis donc une fois que
moi le car est arrivé fermé avec moi je
vais définir les plie donc pour
commencer je le prends de lax niveau des
élastiques 1 toujours du côté élastique
il faut prendre faut faire les clés dont
clacs qui corresponde lac ce qui
correspond donc au milieu de notre tissu
donc on a notre axe et on a notre
deuxième notre premier prix amateur
premier prix à 2 cm
donc d'accord je repose mon boulot et je
reviens oublier dessus plastique nos
gènes mais c'est pas grave
après tout c'est ok après cette phase là
on a notre accent core je le vois moi
mais il est là le maître mot au zoo et
je repris voilà
et là on maintient tout avec les doigts
et on peut partir écoute
le milieu du masque est là et pour
à voir le 2e plie à la rigueur je vais
maintenant jo là à 2 cm notre base ici
replier à l'est à lax et repliée
et m
[Musique]
intérieur extérieur